[Música]
viviendo con su familia en las alturas
en los bosques tropicales del norte de
Colombia encontrarás a Shakira Una muy
conversadora Titi cabeciblanca
Di
hola Aunque tal vez no te des cuenta
este mono de medio kilo se comunica en
un lenguaje altamente sofisticado de 38
os llamados basados en variaciones de
gorjeos y silvidos la respuesta que ella
da es conocida como gorjeo B un llamado
usualmente dirigido a humanos para
apreciar las complejidades del lenguaje
de Shakira aprendamos algunos gorjeos y
silvidos Y luego examinemos cómo sus
combinaciones forman secuencias
estructuradas gramaticalmente el gorjeo
que usa Shakira para saludarnos viene de
una clase de llamados conocida como
sílabas moduladas de una sola encia está
hecha de llamados de corta duración o
gorjeos y llamados largos como
gritos y
chillidos los investigadores han
determinado que hay ocho diferentes
tipos de gorjeos categorizados por su
tronco elevado o no duración frecuencia
máxima y cambio de frecuencia
adicionalmente cada gorjeo tiene su
significado único por ejemplo Shakira
usa el gorjeo
C cuando se acerca a la comida mientras
que su gorjeo
d lo usa Solo cuando tiene la comida en
sus manos los silvidos solos muestran
una intención única con cada llamado y
así como hay ocho gorjeos diferentes hay
cinco silvidos diferentes basados en la
frecuencia de modulación los silvidos
individuales se subdividen en cuatro
categorías
chillidos silvidos modulados al
inicio silvidos modulados al
final y silvidos planos la cualidad de
lenguaje de intención única está
maravillosamente ejemplificada por la
categoría de silvidos modulados al
inicio estos silvidos cambian de acuerdo
a la proximidad de Shakira a otro
miembro de su familia si Shakira está a
más de 60 cm de su familia dará un largo
silvido modulado al
inicio pero si está a menos de 60 cm de
su familia dará un pequeño silvido
modulado al inicio ahora que hemos
aprendido unos pocos gorjeos y silvidos
Shakira quiere presumir llevándote
rápidamente a un día en su vida con
estos llamados mientras se dirige a un
árbol a tomar su primera comida del día
hace un llamado usado en investigaciones
tranquilas sin embargo de repente ve la
sombra de un halcón gorjeo e de alarma
este llamado alerta a su familia de la
presencia de este Depredador y Shakira
salta a ponerse a salvo debajo de una
rama nada en el Horizonte Shakira se
dirige hacia su padre momento momento
Quién es ese ah su hermano menor Carlos
los titis cabes y blancos suelen chillar
mientras juegan a luchar oh oh él está
jugando un poco rudo y Shakira grita
alertando a sus padres para que la
ayuden su padre se acerca a la bola de
pelos rodante y su hermano se detiene
Shakira se sacude y se rasca para poner
el pelo de su cabeza en su lugar
entonces Shakira nota un grupo
desconocido de titís y Oye su usual
llamado largo se vuelve a su
familia capturaste eso primero fue un
gorjeo luego un silvido Esto es lo que
conocemos como vocalización combinada
una frase que contiene tanto un gorjeo
como un silvido Estos son dos llamados
Unidos para transmitir un mensaje la
combinación de estos dos elementos
alerta a su familia de la presencia de
otro grupo El gorjeo F y la distancia a
la cual se encuentran el silvido de
llamado largo normal En otras palabras
Shakira acaba de decir una frase su
simple demostración es solo la punta del
iceberg ella tiene gorjeos
conversaciones múltiples silvidos de
llamado más combinaciones de
vocalizaciones incluso trinos pero lo
más triste es que tal vez no lleguemos a
oír todo lo que ella tiene que decir
mezclado en lo alto con las sonatas de
trinos está el constante ruido de un
machete cortando árboles el hábitat de
Shakira en Colombia está siendo cortado
pieza por pieza y si no trabajamos para
proteger al titab blanco que se
encuentra en peligro crítico se
extinguirá en nuestra vida si el gorjeo
de un Titi a otro ha probado ser más que
una ociosa charla imagina todo lo que
nos queda por descubrir imagina todo lo
que Shakira nos puede
decir quies seguir Aprendiendo
suscríbete a nuestro canal para
satisfacer tu
curiosidad